here ago yesterday that Tim Cook the CEO
of Apple gave a speech at the ADL and
this reach was very surprising to many
people because of its tone it has the
kind of crusading tone to it a a kind of
moral ism and and a kind heroic attitude
in the CEO of Apple and because I talked
about it in my last video on the
symbolism of 666 I thought we could look
at the speech and see it as a very
particularly good example of a symbolism
happens moment where all the elements
are coming together to manifest
something and so what is it manifesting
it seems to have something to do with
the problem of the symbolism of 666 and
so that is what we're going to look at
today
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
now of course when we start the video of
Tim Cook the first thing to know to
notice is of course the tone the tone is
extremely aggressive there's a kind of
certainty in the way that he talks there
is also something about his hand
movements which is extremely extremely
sure of himself and extremely clear that
he has this moral vision that he wants
to accomplish now we have to always
remember that he is not a politician he
isn't a pastor or a priest or a rabbi he
is a CEO of a company that makes tech
that makes signa logical devices we only
have one message for those who seek to
push hate division and violence you have
no place on our platform but I think
it's important to to see how all the
elements come together in this
particular speech which is what makes it
so unsettling this year we've seen the
stubborn and constant evils of
anti-semitism violence and hate
now the first thing he talks about is of
course the he talks about this year and
it's very important to be speaking this
particular year because of the
resurgence of anti-semitism hate and
violence that happened during the year
but also this resurgence of hope and of
people standing up and opening their
eyes you know and it's it's fascinating
to notice that he's also he talks about
how we are a society that is bound by
the values that hold us together and you
wonder what are those values it's very
fascinating because as we most of us
watch the society fragment the question
is what are the values and the thing is
that he will tell you in the speech what
his values are despair is unethical now
the first thing he brings up is this
speech that he saw on this lady who
talked about how it is unethical to
despair now it's very important to
notice this is the first sign of what it
is that he's going to be talking about
that his speech isn't actually about
morality it isn't actually about values
what it is about is about two things and
it is the two things that I showed you
in the symbolism of 666 in my last video
the two things are inclusion and system
that is the only value that really
matters is the value of inclusion and
the only thing that is a problem is that
is is that if you oppose yourself to
that system which is created to include
everybody and you could see it in the
first thing that he says which is that
it is unethical to despair and that is a
crazy statement to make it is crazy to
say that it is unethical to despair
because this fair already is this first
sense of this breakdown which happens in
the margin he frames it first in terms
of meaning and in terms of your place in
the world and your vision for the future
and he says the first thing is that it
is immoral for there to be a something
on the edge of that it is immoral for
there to be a breakdown of that hope it
is unethical and that is that that is a
very fascinating thing and so because it
is unethical then we have to mobilize
ourselves and we have to act we have to
act in order to prevent there from being
despair because despair is itself
unethical the breakdown of meaning is
unethical everything has to fit within
this system or forget that the devices
we make are imagined by human minds
built by human hands and are meant to
improve human lives now the next point
he makes is very fascinating because it
actually seems to make sense he talks
about how he he has a technology company
but that his technology company must
always always remember that it is not
just tech that it is run by people that
it is for people and that the the
purpose of his devices are there to make
the lives of people better that's what
he says but I worry less about computers
that think like people and more about
people that think like computers he
mentioned that he worries more of
out people who think like computers then
computers who think like people and you
would think that this is good because
you say okay here's quality coming back
here's valley coming back into the world
but like I told you this is not about
morality this is actually not about
values in the traditional sense of what
we think of the only values that matter
once again I will repeat it our
inclusion and don't oppose the system of
inclusion those are the two things that
really matter and so let's let's keep
looking and we'll see how it plays out
do not be indifferent to the bloodshed
of your fellow man do not be indifferent
and so he gives us this extremely giveth
this moralizing thing he this moralizing
teaching which he says very
interestingly enough he says do not be
indifferent to the bloodshed of your
fellow man and and he links it to a
teaching from Judaism but then for some
reason he connects it to something that
Muslims did he said he said Muslims also
hold that teaching it's very stretched
connection because he talks about how
Muslims raise money for a shooting which
happened in in a in a synagogue which is
of course praiseworthy but it's trades
that he would connect those two together
and so he says this is a teaching which
is found in all the traditions but then
he says he it's found in Judaism and
it's found in Islam now obviously when
somebody says Trudy is Amman Islam and
then keeps going there's something
missing there's something which is not
part of the that which is not part of
that pattern which seems like there's a
missing element I wonder what it is
he's speaking in the United States to
Americans who come most of all come from
one tradition but like I said this is
this is about inclusion it's about
making sure that all the margins are
included that's the only thing that
matters addressing the center and saying
that this is somehow connected to a
Christian teaching would be going away
from what he wants which is not to
affirm a center but rather just to
include all the margins this mandate
moves us to speak up for immigrants in
verse for those who seek opportunity in
the United States it moves us
to speak up for the LGBTQ community so
and then he proves his point right away
because right away how what examples
does he give the examples of do not
worry about the bloodshed of your fellow
man he could have mentioned a million
things that are happening he could have
mentioned people getting tortured in
China in concentration camps the same
thing happening in Korea there in North
Korea there are there or the slave trade
that is happening in in in Muslim
countries right now he could have to
mention a million things but but what he
mentions is welcome for immigrants and
he also mentions that we need to be
sensitive to the LGBT community now
there's nothing wrong with doing that
there's nothing wrong there's something
it's good to welcome people who are
welcome strangers it's good to to to not
be hostile to those who are our visitors
who will come from the outside it's also
good to not be actively hostile to
people who are living in the margin who
have marginal identities of course but
it strange that those are the examples
that he uses of course he's
participating in a social pattern he's
not thinking only on his own he's
playing out a political narrative that
is that he's not just him but here it's
all Condon's condensated very nicely
into one little speech and so when he
talks about do not so he when he talks
about what his values are he will always
come to this one thing which is
inclusion of of everything in inside
that's why we only have one message for
those who seek to push hate division and
violence and then comes the injunction
and he does it with his finger out and
he's pointing and he's speaking about
how this this religious a thinking of do
not do not that to care about the
bloodshed of your fellow man is bringing
him to one conclusion which is we should
not be indifferent about letting hate
violence ink we enter into their
platforms and so they have to stand up
and stop hey
and violence and all these horrible
things that are on their platform and
you're thinking okay okay I mean I move
along with you and let's see where that
leads you though
because it's a very fascinating thing to
hear coming from a tech company and
especially a tech company that hosts
media you have no place on our platforms
so there's part of us that could cheer
if we could be like okay I mean I I'm a
I'm a traditional person I agree I think
that we shouldn't be pushing hate and
violence and everything and I'm thinking
that's great so I could go maybe I could
go on to iTunes itunes store and check
out to see what's going on and I'm
thinking finally they're going to get
rid of you know those songs in death
metal by bands like war or cannibal
quartz that talking about you know
raping women with knives and and you
know killing and raping children maybe I
could maybe those are the maybe finally
those are gonna go away
they're song by in in in rap music that
talked about similar subjects you know
what about Eminem song where he talks
about being with his daughter and
choking his girlfriend to death and then
burying her with his with his
four-year-old girl maybe finally he's
gonna get rid of those song my friend
he's gonna get rid of that of that stuff
what about all those horror movies that
depict that depict violence and rape and
and murder and torture how about all of
those I mean finally you know you think
Apple is is gonna come on our side gonna
come on the crease inside and get rid of
all that all that crap right well no
that's not what it's about
that is not at all what it's about it is
not about violence and hate and and all
of that it is about one thing and one
thing only it's about exclusion we have
always prohibited music with a message
of white supremacy
why because it's the right thing to do
and as we showed this year we won't give
a platform to violent conspiracy
theorists on the app store why because
it's the right thing to do
and so he attacks two things he says
it's the right thing to do why are we
doing this it's the right thing to do
but he attacks two things he attacks one
thing says white supremacy and you can
kind of understand that I'm not a fan of
white supremacy myself it has been a a
tool for violence in the past it has
been a tool for violent colonization I'm
not a big fan of white supremacy okay
fine but then he says violent conspiracy
theories Oh interesting it's very
fascinating those are the two things
that he mentions he mentions one white
supremacy which is the desire to exclude
or to marginalize all those that aren't
part of your identity and the second is
conspiracy theories that questioned the
government and so I told you it's about
two things
so ID exclusion and questioning the
system and so he will leave on his
platform he will leave Cannibal Corpse
but he will get rid of Alex Jones
because obviously the things out
questioning the narrative and
questioning how the government does
things is extremely dangerous but
talking about necrophilia and and and
horrible things that I can't even
mention that is totally fine that is not
a problem my friends if we can't be
clear on moral questions like these then
we've got big problems it Apple we are
not afraid to say that our values drive
our curation decisions so he tells you
what it's about and it's interesting
because he really does have this
moralistic tone he's like an Inquisitor
he's standing there and he's telling you
this is the truth and so we will impose
it if it wasn't the truth he wouldn't
impose it it's always how any quiz etre
acts right he says you know if it was a
lie I wouldn't impose it on you but
because
it is the truth and it is clear that it
is the truth then why wouldn't I impose
it on you of course I will impose it on
you and it and he says it's the right
thing to do and there again is that
finger pointing at you obviously because
he's not the problem
it's you who are the problem and our
platform is going to solve that problem
and so what world does he want to build
if we believe the future should belong
to those who use technology to build a
better more inclusive and more hopeful
world and so technology should be there
for people who want to build a better so
he gives you three gives you three
better gives you the idea that this is
the value this is a better world but
I'll tell you what a better world is a
better world is more inclusive and
hopeful that is including all the
margins including everything in it and
also not leaving anything on the side
which would question meaning that's what
despair is and so hopeful and inclusion
and it's fascinating because
understanding that that is what they
want and that is really the only thing
that drives them can help you understand
recent things that have been popping up
in the story of Apple can help you
understand why Apple will say that it
opposes hate and violence and is doing
the right thing and is always acting on
its values but then they'll totally
compromise fate in facing China and will
give in to the Chinese government as
they are persecuting protesters because
they are also persecuting protesters
they want to shut down the conspiracy
theories they want to shut down those
that question the system and their
system is a system of absolute inclusion
that is a system that doesn't have a
center except the center of just
including everything and being a total
izing system I believe the most sacred
thing that each of us is given is our
judgment our morality our own innate
desire to separate right from wrong now
this is where the speech now becomes
mythological it really becomes a
symbolism happen moment Tim Cook says
the mo
sacred thing that we have is our
capacity to decide to see what is right
and what is wrong now we have to now
bring everything together we have to not
forget that the very symbolism that
Apple chose for its company is an image
of the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil that is the very symbol that they
used to represent them and and that now
in his speech he is telling you he is
telling you that this is the most sacred
part the highest thing is the knowledge
of good and evil and later in the speech
he will go really further than that and
will even say that it is actually that
we are the divine part we are actually
the divine part that will come out of
the machine and so when he talks he
talks about the story of the god out of
the machine and he says that there's
this trope this ancient trope of the God
out of the machine and in this trope
it's a trope in theatre it was an old
trope to talk about how you know you
solve a narrative problem through
technology you just have a crane which
picks the character up and takes him out
of the of the problem and it was also
this idea that God just appears and just
kind of solves the issue in the
narrative and so the narrative doesn't
resolve itself naturally and so he says
but you can see that he he he there's
something about that that he wants he
understands that there's something about
that that he wants but he doesn't want
the machine to rule he wants us he wants
us to rule he wants us to be the god out
of the machine in the God out of the
machine party says we are the ones who
are the God part now connect that to
what he said just before which is that
our most sacred capacity is to
differentiate good and evil and what do
you have you have the snake in the
garden who is telling Eve to eat the
fruit and that that is how she will be
like God and if the and you can see that
if someone thinks that if someone thinks
that if someone has that pride to think
that they are
like God that that capacity makes them
like God then what will they do they
will have no fear in their action all
their action is going to be turned
towards the outside Tim Cook doesn't
question himself Tim Cook doesn't look
at his own passions at least not in this
speech he's not saying you know that
that he sees the hate hate and the
violence and the prejudice in his own
heart no no it's all outside it's all
them and and we because we are the good
part that we are the ones gonna build
this machine using our divine capacity
to tell the difference between good and
evil we are going to create a system
that has what that has perfect inclusion
and it's a system that you cannot
question and the only sin the only real
sin is to not accept that is to not
accept that system because it's true
right Tim it has to be true if it wasn't
true he wouldn't be imposing it and this
of course is where you forget the full
image of 666 symbolism this notion of an
all-encompassing system which you have
to be part of and that if you question
the system if you refuse it you are not
able to participate in public discourse
you can be fully excluded from the
public space in terms of trade in terms
of voice in terms of place and we can
see that all these tech companies is of
course it's not just Apple but if you
think of Apple and Google and all these
companies and PayPal and the credit card
and all this digital banking that it is
possible and it is seems like it's
happening to create a system that will
that by wanting to include everything
explicitly not leaving things in the
margin I wanted to take the margin and
give it a proper identity will create
this totalizing this totalizing
contradiction of which the only sin will
be to not want to be in the system or to
question the narrative that it is
proposing because it isn't in their idea
a narrative it's the truth it's just the
the fullness from the full reality the
fullness of real
being presented to you so what I hope is
that I hope that this little glimpse
into Tim Cook speech has helped you
understand a little more what I was
talking about in my video on the
symbolism of 666 and I think well I
think also I just want to say we have to
be careful and not pointing fingers that
I'm not saying that Apple is the Apple
is the Beast or what I thought what I'm
saying I'm saying that this process that
we're seeing happening in front of us is
participating in the symbolism of 666
and we need to be attentive to it
because it's going to do what it's going
to do is going to do what is it was is
described in Revelations which is that
if you do not accept their sign on your
forehead or you know in your mind and in
your action if you do not accept their
sign their total inclusion then you will
not be able to participate you will not
be able to participate in society and it
seems like that is the image of the
world that they have and so I hope this
was useful in understanding some more
symbolism and so guys I will see you
soon I'm talking about trading and
participating in society at least for
now it is still possible to engage and I
designed some some new things for for
the Christmas season of two t-shirts and
some new merchandise people seem to be
appreciated and it was even shared by
Rod Dreher
on Twitter the t-shirt on the six days
of creation so check it out you still
have a few days to order it so then
it'll arrive before Christmas so
it just did go ahead and things a lot
everybody for your support don't forget
to subscribe also to the clips channel
which is putting stuff all almost
everyday I think thank you for the
volunteers where I involved in that I
will talk to everybody very soon